be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are getting back into DC
stand here's the thing we actually
missed one of the tie-in stories there's
actually you have the main DC stu title
itself which is six issues and then you
have a good day to die and initially I
didn't really plan on covering a good
day to die
mostly because I didn't read it and then
I sat down and read it and I was like
this is amazing we need to cover this
because deceased itself the main six
issue limited series it deals largely
with the most well known superheroes
right the cool thing about the the good
day to die is it deals with like some
still pretty prominent superheroes but
actually kind of takes it from a
different direction so it's really
really cool the way it goes down so
initially this picks up with scot-free
and big Barda now those you guys who are
unfamiliar with this brand do a lot of
explaining in this for people who are
unfamiliar with it but firfer scot-free
and and big Barda released mr. miracle
as a lot of you guys probably know on em
big Barda their home is essentially
apocalypse for mister miracle it was and
then sometimes it is sometimes it's not
the way this works in in DC Comics is
you have two worlds more or less after
the events like crisis on Infinite
Earths they were actually in a singular
universe as it exists now and the new
vision - and it's part of DC rebirth
they're actually out there in their own
place really within the multiverse
itself but you end up having the planet
of apocalypse and the planet of New
Genesis and they're really designed to
kind of represent good and evil that's
how they were designed by Jack Kirby
when he wrote the fourth world but the
idea is that New Genesis is home to hi
father and of course apocalypse is home
to Darkseid and the initial basis behind
this is that the two groups were
basically at war with each other and so
in order to broker a peace Abbey by the
name of Metatron came along and
basically had them swap sons so so
essentially the son of hi father went
over to went to apocalypse and the son
of apocalypse went to new Genesis and so
as a result it was a way to basically
keep the peace so that neither would
destroy the others world in by virtue of
that kill their own sons with scott-free
would hit with him going over to
apocalypse he basically doesn't live
like this really crappy life where he
was in a cell all the time eventually he
learned how to pick the lock and because
this the the locks for apocalypse are so
difficult to pick ultimately it meant
that he basically became like the best
lock picker ever but on the last big bar
that was part of the Furies and the fury
was basically like an all-female team
with some occasional guys in there that
served as basically like agents of
apocalypse and were trained by granny
goodness it was a pretty cool idea but
essentially these two folks are
basically like okay like Darkseid's dead
apocalypse has been destroyed now we got
to leave now there is no reference here
to new Genesis there's no reference to
it we can assume it exists I mean the
two kind of exists in offices
Hulse one another but there's no
reference to it so we can just kind of
you know roll with that but what it does
is it switches over to Michael Holt also
known as mr. terrific now again mr.
terrific is one of the smartest people
in the world I think he's probably in
the top three but mr. terrific has
basically been conducting experiments on
Captain Boomerang right like an infected
person he's an exposed him to another
dose of the virus to see if there's any
kind of change
there's no stimulus no response to being
touched or anything like that so
essentially he's just sort of a nonhuman
entity right like whatever sense of
humanity he had has long since been gone
now so where you end up having Scott
free and Barda who go back to their
apartment are they end up getting a
knock on the door this is where the
reasons why I love Scott free right
because he's a humorous character if
he's written correctly like he's
supposed to be he's hilarious
and initially like he makes this comment
like when they hear a knock at the door
it's like whoa maybe somebody with like
a bloody stump I have no earthly clue of
course once they answer it it turns out
to be mr. terrific but it's one of these
things where he's essentially been
analyzing the the whole situation now of
course this is a role that would
normally be reserved for Batman but as
we know Bruce Wayne's basically dead
he's he's out of the picture now and so
because of this Michael Holt's been
trying to deduce and trying to figure
out what's going on and ultimately his
initial idea was if the virus originated
from apocalypse that we can travel there
and we can basically try to find a cure
no guarantees there but now it's
basically out the window because
apocalypse has been completely destroyed
and so following that their response is
well then we only have one other real
choice that we can use we can basically
try to invoke like the powers of magic
and so what it does is it transitions
over the court industries with Booster
Gold and with with with Ted Kord himself
the Blue Beetle now again this is kind
of a cool thing but this is somebody
else's sort of interesting here is
because of the nature of the situation
and the nature of the story normally we
would expect Tom Taylor to write Booster
Gold not so much in a in a goofball way
I mean he really is kind of a goofy
character but we would expect him to be
written in a way where he's more of like
not only the comic relief but something
close to it and this he's not written
that way now the cool thing about that
is one of the reasons why so many fans
love Booster Gold is because depending
on who's writing the story he can be a
very dynamic character if it's a rider
that doesn't really care anything about
him he's done in a throwaway fashion
he's just kind like here's the guy who's
a goofball he's a buffoon
and you throw him away that way but if
he's written effectively he can be one
of the more dynamic characters in the
entirety of DC right because he's the
guy that everybody knows is basically a
dude from the future who went to the
past
and essentially faked being a hero from
the future in order to try to be a hero
in the present day because he was a
loser in the future he's always kind of
kind of a chip on his shoulder
but in this instance it's one of these
pretty hardcore situations because with
everything sort of popping off the way
that it is the response is like we
basically need you guys like like we
need you Booster Gold in order to help
us you know achieve this particular goal
but before we do this we're gonna see we
can't find a way to cure it with magic
and so of course what they end up doing
is traveling to England and we pick up
with John Constantine now the funny
thing about this is that magic in DC is
is sort of intriguing whether those are
guys who were reading DC rebirth right
now or I guess really it's DC universe
now there was a big reference to to how
magic works right especially in Doomsday
Clock that initially magic was just a
thing that existed in DC and it kind of
had some some ties to a bit of reality
warping and there was also sort of tried
and true Witchcraft and Wizardry
what dr. Manhattan revealed by virtue of
Doomsday Clock is that all people who
were doing when they manipulate magic is
they're essentially manipulating reality
but on a much smaller scale and they're
doing it with what are essentially the
leftovers of the various properties of
the universe that are out there but the
fact remains here that is kind of being
treated in this situation or at least
being viewed by mr. terrific it's kind
of a catch-all right like if we have
people who can use magic we can just
sort of wish it all away and everything
will be okay and then everything will be
fine that'll be it you know of course
picking up with Constantine we learned
that's not the case and the reason why
is because of this guy fleeing for his
life if magic could easily be used or
could be channeled in a way to where it
could essentially solve solve all the
problems well then all it would take is
like dr. fate and cetana and a handful
of other people probably Ettrick in to
come along with Constantine and then go
from city to city snapping their fingers
and everything will be okay or one great
big huge giant spell that they create in
order to cure the world and everything
would be done in like one issue but with
Constantine fleeing for his life like
this and then ultimately having to
incinerate his best friend Chas who's
been converted it really kind of shows
us that like there's no real hope here
and that's what Constantine tells mr.
terrific right when terrific shows up
and says hey look like essentially like
we need magic in order to basically cure
this the response of Constantine is like
what do you think I can do just snap my
fingers and everything is fixed buddy if
I could have done that I would have done
it a long time ago it doesn't work that
way like magic doesn't work that way and
and even if it did these folks can't be
saved in that fashion they're not human
anymore the only thing you can really do
is is kill them and so as a results of
this because magic is not an option they
move on to Plan C and that involves
Booster Gold basically going back in
time and appealing in the timestream in
order
the initial infection from breaking out
and so where everybody essentially shows
up here and then all hell breaks loose
as soon as they arrive right you got
like big Barda and scot-free who
basically fall they end up dying or at
least being consumed by these zombies
once Ted Kord and once mr. terrific and
Booster Gold to get inside this room
they're immediately met by wave rider
now wave rider is an old-school
character well not super old-school he's
relatively old-school he appeared back
in 1991 with a story called Armageddon
2001 and the idea behind this story as
it was written by Archie Goodwin is it
was basically designed to kind of show
like possible futures right it was the
first real instance of DCE basically
portraying the possibility of time
travel and even even slower than poking
to a degree the aspect of Hypertime
which would later be sort of evolved
even more by by Mark Waid and N and
Grant Morrison but sort of showing like
possible futures for the various
characters that were out there now it
was a two issue miniseries with a whole
bunch of clients to it but Waverider was
basically a guy who came from a future
where some hero in the modern day would
basically go forward ended up killing
all the superheroes and his goal was to
prevent that and so after learning how
to are really being endowed with the
ability to manipulate the timestream
this led to him becoming the character
over a wave rider and then becoming one
of the linear men and the linear men are
basically like like time police is
really what they are like their job is
to monitor the time stream and to make
sure nobody does anything that's
supposed to screw stuff up and this is a
really smart move by Tom Taylor because
the reality is that DC's as it's written
is exceedingly good and in truth Tom
Taylor would have essentially just kind
of pissed it all away had it turned into
a situation where time-travel
everything's fixed it really goes into a
scenario where the Waverider says you
cannot manipulate the time stream like
this is the fate of your universe you
can't escape this is this how it's
supposed to unfold sorry about your luck
I don't know what to tell you like it's
kind of funny the way plays out it's
kind of messed up the way it plays out
but initially Constantine didn't want to
have anything to do with this right he's
like you guys go off and do your own
thing
I'm gonna go teleport to someplace I'm
gonna find a bar and I'm just gonna get
drunk until everything around us comes
crashing down and so as a result of this
you know there really doesn't really
seem to be an alternative or inability
to stop Waverider right I mean you're
talking about a guy who can manipulate
quantum energy he could incinerate Ted
Kord and Booster Gold like that's right
in the blink of an eye and his jaw here
even is to basically arrest Booster Gold
and take him back to the future and so
because of this John Kaase and teens
sitting in this bar viciously sort of
Rick Hansen says okay fine
gotta go be a hero right I mean his
conscience gets the better of him and so
as a result of that he shows up he
headbutts waver
and that basically says I'll hold them
off only for the entire group to be met
with the arrival of big Barda who
literally rips mr. terrific in half
which is kind of insane to see and so
all you really have left is Booster Gold
Blue Beetle then you got Constantine
holding off Waverider is best he can't
but because of the fact that Michael
Holt's been killed and because of the
fact that in the next part of this video
that we're gonna talk about here in a
second that in events taking place and
we'll cover that you once we get to it
that basically the future where Booster
Gold comes from doesn't exist anymore
humanity as it exists and his timeline
is gone and so because that is kind of
cool to see that like linear time is
maintained meaning that whatever happens
in the present day affects the future is
an absolute outcome essentially Booster
Gold ceases to be he basically fades
from existence and so as a result of
that there's no real means to travel
back in time and to fix everything and
then of course in response to that
Constantine bonds himself to Waverider
and basically says where you go I go
there's no way for you to escape from me
but the problem with that is that
basically wave riders out of the picture
now wave riders been destroyed because
he's killed by Ted Kord and so again
it's a really good way for Tom Taylor to
kind of say hey are we gonna use time
travel no we're not and then just move
on to the next thing
Nick is following that with it all kind
of going belly-up and all the plans and
really all these superheroes being
killed suddenly you have the arrival of
Zatanna
dr. fate Bobo and a couple a couple
other people who basically say hey look
like this world is doomed there's
nothing you can do here come with us and
and we're just gonna move on to a better
place and wait for whatever happens next
and the response of Constantine is not a
chance the world doesn't end until I say
it does and so at this point we switch
over to decease number 5 itself and this
is one of the really cool things because
what it does is it shows the response of
humanity in the process of how all this
went down
specifically the government's and what
it shows us is that like all the major
at least some of those you know three of
the major cities in the US have been
totally obliterated Washington d.c
Baltimore and metropolis totally
incinerated and completely gone and it's
kind of crazy to see because the Green
Lantern was able to save a handful of
people here in there but for the most
part virtually everybody in Metropolis
is dead and one of the crazy things
about this and it's one of the coolest
moments in the story you know finding
out that Lex Luthor is alive and where
Superman shows up on his doorstep you
know shows up there with the intention
of kind of being like what's one more
dead body
Lex Luthor actually breaks down and it's
a great moment here it's insanely cool
the way it's written because when you
have these two guys you know that the
the battles between Lex Luthor and
Superman are timeless right they're some
of the greatest conflicts you're ever
going to
see because it's the mine of Lex Luthor
against the Brawn of Superman right and
despite how smart Superman is it usually
comes down to a physical altercation
although sometimes it does sort of focus
on battles of the mind
but here Lex Luthor just sort of begins
to cry and just says like look what
happened to our city and that's the most
important you know the most important
takeaway here is that more important
than any one of these two guys is their
allegiance how much they die you the
city of Metropolis because it's their
home and so it's a it's a beautiful
moment here because they have common
ground our entire city has been totally
obliterated all we really have left is
each other
and so what Tom Taylor does is give us a
kind of timeline and say over the course
of the next few days and then the next
few weeks various efforts are undertaken
in order to sort of try to save what's
left of humanity right like all these
various servers are destroyed by the
flash all around the world so the
Internet is taken down as best as it can
be you end up having like mass
satellites that are out there that are
broadcasting you know TV shows or radio
signals or whatever it is those are
taken out by Wonder Woman all these
things are basically implemented by the
superheroes in order to take down modern
technology not only that what they also
need is a refuge right because if Earth
is almost completely overrun then what's
left of of humanity that has not been
infected needs a place to stay otherwise
it's only a matter of time before
they're completely destroyed and so what
it does is it leads to Wonder Woman
traveling to Paradise Island and
basically saying like we'd to house
people here and for the most part this
is a big no-no right Paradise Island is
cut off from everything like it's one of
these things were sort of like no one
comes here people aren't allowed to be
here we don't let men onto our island
it's just something you don't do is
something that you just don't see and
it's kind of a cool theme because in
response to this Wonder Woman's
statement is basically I'm a protector
of Earth I'm here to protect the world
and if humanity has fallen as fast and
there's superheroes around there and
superheroes have fallen how long do you
really think it'll be before people show
up here and so in order to basically
keep this place protected as best we can
one we need to have individuals out
there who are who are innocents who did
nothing wrong and are just cut in the
hole you know caught up in the whole
circumstance we need to be able to house
them here because it's the right thing
to do and to really take what's left of
the superhero community and provide some
measure of protection right because
we're the Amazons are powerful at the
end of the day if you're talking about a
vast amount of an infected or somehow
find their way they're talking about
just like a battle of attrition and so
as a result of that you end up having
Green Lantern's Superman and Wonder
Woman who essentially lift the island up
a little bit higher and then you go to
Gotham and you get one of the coolest
moments in the whole story right because
what you end up learning is that over
the course of a week an entire Jeong
grew throughout the entire city of
Gotham and of course that's when you end
up learning that is poison ivy that made
that happen
now of course Killer Croc tries to
attack you know Batman and and and and
Green Arrow and Dinah Lance the new the
new Green Lantern tries to attack him
he's taken out you know bye-bye poison
ivy less we end up learning poison ivy
used her power of the dream to create a
kind of safe haven in the entirety of
Gotham but the funny thing about this is
the only people allowed in are the
people she allows in and at the moment
it only really seems to be Harley Quinn
and in poison ivy herself and Harley
this is kind of a cool moment Harley has
actually been advocating to turning it
into a refuge and saying look like you
have all this stuff here right like
you've grown vines here and there's this
great big huge thorn wall and like none
of the undead can get in here so like
let innocent people in and for the most
part poison ivy doesn't really seem to
have want to do it but then when you
have Batman everybody's showing up and
you have Damian Wayne basically saying
look Bruce Wayne's dead right like my
father's dead I'm the new Batman now
poison ivy begins to kind of filled form
because it really is a kind of
realization of how bad things are and so
as a result of that knowing that Bruce
Wayne is gone knowing that Damian Wayne
is taking up the mantle and realizing
things are really just this dire
ultimately poison ivy gives in and the
response is you know of course don't
harm any of the trees or anything like
that and Damian Wayne answers like we'll
agree to any terms and so what it does
is it switches over to the fortress of
solitude
now the fortress of solitude itself is
not really big enough to house all these
innocent people otherwise I would have
said like why not turn that place into a
refuge it wasn't designed for that right
it's simply not that big but it is big
enough to become a new Hall of Justice
right for what's left of the superhero
community to essentially work together
and it's kind of a cool moment here
because you have all these folks
basically gathered around saying here's
where things stand
you've got firestorm Ronnie Raymond
you've got Power Girl you've got a lot
of these superheroes here who are
basically doing the best they can to
sort of keep everything under control to
keep their heads level you got Lex
Luthor who's starting some nonsense but
one of the big things is basically being
worked on here is the creation of arcs
and the creation of arcs are a really
cool idea because basically what it
means is it allows humanity or at least
it seems to allow humanity to basically
sort of finding a way to escape and it's
kind of crazy because initially the
response to Superman is we're not
leaving we're not going to leave this
planet we're not going to abandon our
home and Lex Luthor sort of chimes in
and just kind of like you know the human
race is in it isn't like a fight to
survive but it has to leave the planet
and it's kind of interesting because
these are two opposing ideologies for
Lex Luthor earth is his home right but
it's kind of like in order for Humanity
survive
to leave here we have to go someplace
else but Superman lost his home right
his home was destroyed before he was old
enough to really do anything about it
and one of the big on running themes
about Superman is trying to find a way
to maintain his home trying to find a
way to either reconnect with Krypton or
protect earth as best he can and there's
got to be a little bit of guilt here if
earth is destroyed that it's like
Superman failed right in the idea of him
failing and losing another home is
really too much for him to deal with and
so it's kind of like we can't simply
just leave here but in the end you end
up having like the mom of Superman and
you know coming in Martha basically
coming in and saying hey look it's the
only real choice that we have they're
able to kind of talk him down a little
bit now of course Lex Luthor basically
achons and you know like man losing two
worlds in a lifetime it sucks to be you
Lois Lane punches the heck out of him
it's hilarious and she puts a haymaker
on him and then she sees Jonathan when
he when she realizes that he saw what
she did and he's like aah violence is
never the answer Jonathan and that
that's true violence is never the answer
that is a very true that is a very true
statement
however violence is a answer and it's a
very effective answer right like
violence gets things done and so it's
it's it's kind of crazy because with
these arcs basically being built as a
means to get humanity off the off the
face of the planet and with these
various refuges serving as a place for
Humanity to reside until that time it
really starts to give people hope it
gives people the ability and really the
belief now there's other places they can
go to my community with our community
with a Green Lantern ring saying like
where are other places we can go but
ultimately what they end up realizing is
that none of them were ever in control
and the reason why is because while all
this is going down suddenly they're met
with this kind of buzzing sound and then
it begins to get louder and louder and
begins to drive them insane only for us
to find out that when Lex Luthor dies
this is the Martian Manhunter and the
Martian Manhunter is infected now this
is a big deal and the reason why is
because if you go and you read the JLA
stories by Grant Morrison one of the
things that DC shows and actually states
them in multiple instances is that the
Martian Manhunter is the most powerful
being on earth he has all the abilities
of Superman plus he can shape-shift and
he can read minds right now he is afraid
of fire you know I said well sometimes
he is sometimes he's not it's just a
weakness whatever the case is but like
fire is basically the best way to combat
it but having a somebody out there who
can shape-shift into pretty much
anything and then suddenly show up and
attack the entirety of the superhero
community almost guarantees destruction
for all of them however they have Ronnie
Raymond on their side they have
firestorm who of course uses his powers
Antonius incinerates Martian Manhunter
the problem with this is that when that
happens the flash Barry Allen is
attacked and he's infected and this is
probably the worst case situation
because he immediately takes off running
and the reason why this is bad is
because you're talking about the fastest
man alive
who can basically infect the world and
he does it in the blink of an eye almost
no survivors are left basically he just
like runs around from place to place
before they even realize there's anybody
there
they're infected you know and it's it's
insane how fast it happens and so super
Madison responds by saying hey look I
can't really catch up with him but I can
meet him on the other side and this is
one of the coolest things because what
he does basically fly out you know to
the moon and then fly back as fast as he
possibly can and basically crash
directly into Barry Allen and where
Barry Allen's totally destroyed in the
process he's cut in half the issue with
this is that some of the bones end up
ripping into Superman so now he's
infected and is one of the saddest
moments ever because what this means is
the world is doomed there's no escape
here humanity has Rashed
and he manikin try to escape but
Superman could eradicate those things in
the blink of an eye a guy who could fly
into space and hold his breath for a
pretty lengthy amount of time and then
of course has all those powers based on
the abilities of solar radiation is is
insanely cool the only way to really get
around this would be to like retrofit
the various ships with like green
kryptonite but you would have to do it
in such a way to where the area of
effect of that green kryptonite is so
far out the Superman can't even get
remotely close but you're talking about
a guy with telescopic vision so he could
be far enough away that he could use his
heat vision and then shoot them and then
destroy them right so I mean it's kind
of nuts now ultimately the goal of
Superman seemingly you know seeming as
an infected person would be to spread
the infection not necessarily just kill
people and so if Tom Taylor stays true
to what he's been doing so far then
retrofitting the ships with green
kryptonite is the only real hope they
have but at the moment they don't really
seem to have any because as they sort of
look around Superman starts meeting with
everybody he knows his fates his fate is
sealed and everybody else does too
Lois really says her goodbyes and and
she's like you know thank you for
choosing me and it's such an incredibly
touching moment thank you for choosing
me thank you for making this place your
home thank you for loving me and it's
kind of crushing because in turn he
speaks to John and says like you're the
one running the show now you're the man
of the house now like you have to make
sure everybody stays safe the fate of
humanity rests on your shoulders and it
seems like it'd be a huge amount of
pressure to bestow on a child and it is
but it's also the reality of the
situation that's really what's going on
here is that it really all
does come down to Jonathan but that's
why I love DC so much it's because this
is things just getting insanely dire
things are getting really really bad
because what's basically happened here
is that now that Martian Manhunter is
gone the most powerful superhuman in the
world is infected and that's literally
what's said here
is that with what the infection of
Superman hope was gone along with the
entirety of their world there's no real
saving anybody anymore but when that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the rod
4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]